[Music]
do
so
good evening everyone it is hot outside
but good thing the wind is blowing
because it makes it a teeny bit less hot
so glad you guys are here with us
tonight um
i have a few announcements before we
jump into a service that has been made
just for you
um next week may 15th right after the
service we'll be having a welcome to the
table class so if you are interested in
becoming a member or you have questions
you are more than welcome to that please
rsvp if you are wanting to come to that
you can do that online
you can send a text or there are welcome
cards for visitors to put your
information in and you could just write
on the back of it
wtt welcome
welcome to the three t's
we don't if you do too many t's we're
not going to know what you're talking
about so make sure
um and then may 29th we will not be
having service two sundays a year we
like to
take it off and give our volunteers a
break and just use that sunday to rest
it's memorial day weekend so
may 29th don't come here
um as y'all know it's a really special
day it's mother's day
and yeah it's a good one i'm a mom so
thanks happy mother's day
and i have this really sweet um tribute
that i would like to read and share with
y'all and um as i read it it's going to
give definitions of all variations of
moms and i invite you to close your eyes
and try and picture or just allow the
spirit to give you a picture of some of
these
women who fit this
these different definitions um
yeah so if you would like to close your
eyes and just take a posture of
listening and
trying to picture these these women
to those who gave birth this year to
their first child we celebrate you
to those who are in the trenches with
little ones every day and wear the badge
of food stains we appreciate you
to those who experienced loss through
miscarriage failed adoptions running
away or the loss of a child we mourn
with you
to those who walk the hard path of
infertility fraught with pokes prods
tears and disappointment we walk with
you
forgive us when we say foolish things we
don't mean to make this harder than it
is to those who are foster moms mentor
moms and spiritual moms we need you
to those who have warm and close
relationships with your children we
celebrate you
to those who have disappointment
heartache and distance with your
children we sit with you
to those who lost their mothers this
year's
we grieve with you
to those who experience abuse at the
hands of your own mother we acknowledge
your experience
to those who lived through driving tests
medical tests and the overall testing of
motherhood we are better for having you
in our midst
to those who are single and long to be
married and mothering your own children
we mourn that life has not turned out
the way you longed for it to be
to those who step parent we walk with
you on these complex paths
to those who envisioned lavishing love
on grandchildren yet that dream is not
to be we grieve with you
to those who will have empty or nest in
the upcoming year we grieve and rejoice
with you
to those who place children up for
adoption we commend you for your
selflessness and remember how you hold
that child in your heart
and to those who are pregnant with new
life both expected and surprising we
anticipate with you
this mother's day we walk with you
mothering is not for the faint of heart
and we have real warriors in our midst
today
we remember you
[Music]
i know you're tired i see it in your
i'll be your shield when you don't feel
like you've got strength enough to fight
i'll stand by your side
i will carry
you
[Music]
i will carry
you
[Music]
i choose you as you are a billion times
cause i am not ashamed of you
i won't walk away from you
i will carry
you
through the darkest nights
i
will carry
you
when the water
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
[Applause]
through your darkest night
[Music]
i will carry you
thank you joe would you guys stand with
us and worship with us you are welcome
in this space
and we're going to sing brighter days
[Music]
in my veins i know there's gonna be some
brighter tears
i know there's gonna be some brighter
days
[Music]
i know there's gonna be some brighter
days
[Applause]
[Music]
i know
i know there's gonna be some brighter
days
[Music]
[Applause]
all the time
[Music]
i know
i know there's gonna be some brighter
days
[Music]
with us
is
[Music]
[Applause]
i know
[Music]
awesome kids you guys are released to go
to kids ministry
and i am gonna pray for us real quick
jesus thank you so much for this time
together
thank you for the way that you meet us
in this space where we open up our
hearts and our mouths
and say things to you that we want to be
true
say things to you that we need to
believe sometimes even when we don't
feel it
[Music]
when we need to hope even though things
might seem a little hopeless
when we need light even though around us
it feels very dark
god would we find you in those places
[Music]
because you are there
you are carrying us
[Music]
me
anymore
when i
see your face
everything changes in the
radiance of your smile
[Music]
chasing away those
shadows that hang
around i fall
down
again
[Music]
i'm finding out just who
i
am
i lose my ability
to feel afraid
[Music]
[Applause]
everything changes
[Music]
shadows
i'm finding out
just who
i
am again
i'm finding out just who
i am
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
everything
[Music]
taking away those
shadows again
just who
i am
[Music]
just who
i
am
[Music]
yes god thank you for this time together
god would you continue to speak to us
help us to have open hearts and open
ears god
and would you meet us in all the spaces
that we need to hear your voice
would we hear you say our name would we
know your love
and your closeness
[Music]
thank you god for this time together
it's in your name we pray
amen
you guys can be seated and as you do
would you turn to the people around you
and welcome them make them feel at home
and brett will come and start our
grace and messages
it is so good to be with all of you and
a very happy mother's day as well
um
i'm i'm just i'm really grateful i'm
grateful
to be with all of you i'm grateful
for my mom i'm grateful um
just for i think just the chance to um
be
just to be here to be present together
that's really that's quite a gift um so
i also want to welcome those joining us
online
love you lots you're not forgotten the
the online folks can sometimes um i
wonder if they feel a little bit i don't
know well somewhat unseen but we uh we
remember you i'm thinking of james uh
gail uh various others who are often
with us so um love you all lots and also
i want to extend a warm welcome to um
those of you who are new and maybe just
kind of finding your way into the
community thank you um so much for being
here so um we're in a series
right now and we're going to be
continuing on through that series and uh
so it's it's titled first peter part
three and we're basically just walking
our way through the book of
you guessed it
first peter still gonna keep going maybe
in a 2024 i don't know we'll just see
hold on
[Laughter]
don't worry we're uh we're gonna make it
we will be hitting the pause button in a
few weeks um it's uh it's i do i think
it's one of those well the book i mean
for those of you who have been with us
like it's just it can be really intense
um
it kind of has these like peaks these
mountain peaks are like incredibly
beautiful and then it has some kind of
like valleys of just like oh gosh which
we had to work through all sorts of
texts in chapter three and it was it's
all crazy but um i do see some value in
just like going through a book of the
bible you know and it's easy to kind of
settle into a rhythm where it's like i
just kind of i just pick and choose the
parts that i like and kind of ignore
everything else i think it's better to
um learn to grapple with it all
and it often is a wrestling with it you
know i mean it's it's not i think of uh
jacob um in the story of wrestling with
the angel slash the spirit slash gods
like you know sort of a sort of
ambiguous who he was wrestling with that
story in the old testament um
but i i wonder if that's uh i mean
ultimately he got his name changed in
that wrestling match from jacob to
israel that became kind of the the name
for like the people of god like those
who wrestle and i think that's kind of
our posture you know isn't passive with
with god with the bible it's one of real
just engagement so um i think that's the
upside to going through a book um
so with that in mind that the title of
my message is jesus and the powers that
be
you can tell right away this isn't like
a super mother's day kind of message i
don't i don't tend to do a lot of those
um so our text is gonna be first peter
chapter three
uh verses 18-22 kind of the second part
of verse eighteen uh and it says this
christ was put to death in the body but
made alive in the spirit after being
made alive he went and made proclamation
to the imprisoned spirits to those who
were disobedient long ago when god
waited patiently in the days of noah
while the ark was being built
in it only a few people eight and all
were saved through water and this water
symbolizes baptism that now saves you
also not the removal of dirt from the
body but the pledge of a clear
conscience towards god it saves you by
the resurrection of jesus christ who has
gone into heaven and is at god's right
hand with angels authorities and powers
in submission to
him
crystal clear
am i right um
dude this is a complicated text it was
actually i was reading like you know of
course going through various
commentaries and trying to get scholarly
you know perspectives on this and there
were a number of new testament scholars
who said this passage is the single most
confusing and difficult to interpret in
the entire new testament like in their
opinion and i mean if you've read the
new testament you know like the apostle
paul has the book of romans this is like
really challenging text this one is like
it's kind of going everywhere i mean it
starts off with this sort of
proclamation about jesus you know he's
put to death in the body but then he's
made alive you know
kind of cross resurrection made alive in
the spirit and then he's like after
being made alive then he went and made
proclamation to the imprisoned spirits
which we'll get to in a second of like
what is he talking about and uh and it's
been who are these spirits those were
disobedient long ago then he starts
talking about noah they're the ones who
waited patiently in the days of noah and
then as though that gets him to thinking
about like huh
the ark and then he's like oh and that's
sort of like a symbol of like you who
are saved and this actually i think this
is kind of talking about baptism and
he's like now what i mean by baptism is
not the removal of dirt from the body
he's like actually it's about it's like
our minds it's like a clear it's about a
clear conscience before christ and then
he starts going into uh now that i'm
thinking about jesus oh and jesus he's
the ascended one
and now he's he's uh the rule he's at
the right hand of god a symbol of
authority to all angels and powers and
can you see how it's just sort of like
thought to thought to thought to that
like what is going on so here's what i
do is kind of back up like all right
let's slow it down i want to start with
kind of explaining where others have
gone kind of in church history we're
talking like way back when all the way
there's even a few modern scholars who
um kind of give this
a a a certain interpretation of this and
um it is what uh the the ancients uh
what they used to call the harrowing of
hell which sounds fascinating
i see
i won't say who but certain people's
face just went
what
the hero anyone
familiar with the harrowing of hell
anyone
i know i'm sure some of you are like i
actually do know but i really don't want
to raise my hand right now um
so heroin basically means like uh
assault or or battle
and the way this was interpreted for
years and years um in the christian
tradition was that this was basically
the a time if you've ever wondered what
was jesus doing in between the cross and
resurrection
the answer would be harrowing hell
heroin kind of fighting like basically
the idea was
holy saturday he go he descends down
into hell he preaches to the souls there
this would be coming back to verse 19
where it says after being made alive he
went and made proclamation to the
imprisoned spirits
and so for a long time in church history
that was kind of the reading was like
aha
the spirits
he's going down into how he's he's
making proclamation to the souls of the
damned basically
now you might think so to announce
judgment upon them like oh you sinners
look what you did to me put me on that
cross and now i condemn you all no that
wasn't the theology instead the idea was
actually the opposite he goes into hell
to bring all those back
um to draw people out um which is kind
of a beautiful i think beautiful idea um
and there's there's a number of if
you've ever very familiar with icons
christian icons um
can be they're often paintings like a
certain form of christian art and i
think we have an image of one icon
because the
i think they would be called
iconographers they loved the idea of the
harrowing of hell the painters they love
this idea and you can kind of see there
on the what is it kind of right side you
got the
satan and the demons you know and then
there's christ on the left and he's sort
of bringing the people you know out of
hell and they love this you know kind of
image um
now i'm if you have been to the table a
while you know
um kind of in my my own um like theology
i'm very like sympathetic to this this
kind of
idea um because basically what you had
is like this is kind of different than
we think of hell you know in the
christian west um
it's usually kind of in our mind sort of
like hell is the place it's like forever
eternal torture and damnation of the
souls you know um in the east it was
seen more temporary
kind of a process a place you went to go
through and then eventually
to um return to god
and uh so i'm quite sympathetic to that
vision um i just i don't think actually
this text is talking about that i think
other verses kind of indicate that but i
just don't think this one is i'm going
to give you a few reasons um and i don't
want to get too nerdy here trust me hang
with me
i will take this somewhere i will
hopefully it'll land in your life at
least in some way um
but but let me uh let me try to to
unpack this a little bit because i do
wanna you know it's important learn
things from the bible so um
so let me give you i'm gonna give you
three reasons why i don't think it is so
first um it talks about you know um
verse 20 oh it's talking about those
souls who were disobedient back in the
days of noah right if you caught it it's
um
starting verse 19. after being made
alive he went and made proclamation to
the imprisoned spirits verse 20 to those
who were disobedient long ago when god
waited patiently in the days of noah
while the ark was being built um so it'd
be a little bit strange to be like he's
heroin hell he goes and he's like all
right i'm here come with me but only
those who were in the days of noah now
anyone later sorry you have to stay but
the rest of you you're free to come with
me you know to have it like that would
be can you see how that would be a
little bit strange like i'm here in hell
but only for like some of the souls you
know um that would be a that's that
would be a strange idea um a second
reason is it's pretty clear that text
makes it pretty clear this is the
resurrected jesus not like
the in-between state you know not um in
between cross and resurrection but i
mean in its first um was it 19 after
being made what
alive you know um he went and made
proclamation to the imprisoned spirits
um a third reason is just the language
of spirits in general that's just kind
of a weird
like the new testament just doesn't do
that a lot to like refer to human beings
as you spirits you know it's like
it's um
that's not really the language so um
with that in mind what's going on here i
think verse 22 is pretty pretty key the
very closing passage it says jesus
christ who has gone into heaven and is
at god's right hand with angels
authorities and powers in submission to
him i think actually what this is this
is um christ's sermon to what paul and
other new testament writers will call
the principalities and the powers
basically um
like demonic kind of forces or evil
spirits and jesus um
is
i think this is actually about the the
not only resurrected but ascended christ
who then declares to everything sort of
unclean and evil
um
judgment and like you've done
enough
it's over the game's up
uh i'm lord i think that's kind of
what's going on now keep in mind um you
know the the
the culture of the new testament it's it
was just so different than ours today
you know like people back then um and
even some different cultures
uh on uh today but not so much ours like
we're modern kind of secular people you
know
um
those cultures they've really lived in
fear of evil spirits demonic beings like
that was very much um
very much a thing whereas like for us
you know modern people the tendency is
for us like when we see
a bad person we just think well look
there they go bad people doing bad
things
not surprised you know whereas ancient
christians they would have seen someone
under the sway of the principalities and
the powers um
i think um
like so let me give you a few examples
um
like someone like say vladimir putin
right as modern people kind of see the
invasion of ukraine all this happening
and we just envision we see a leader
again perfect exam like just a bad
person doing bad things just evil that's
just evil um
ancient christians would see someone
under the sway of the principalities and
the powers right they very much
understood that there are um kind of
forces behind the scenes in human
history um
uh it's gonna be the opposite of our
easter sermon if you're here for easter
you remember it was the whole idea that
jesus calls us by name
and draws us towards love instead of
hatred
um
hope
instead of despair forgiveness
instead of um bitterness
and like this is what christ does so
this would basically be the opposite of
that right this would be those evil
forces those kind of voices in our heads
those accusing voices
that tear us down
um those voices of addiction and chaos
and evil
um
that operate kind of can mess with us
and just in in culture kind of calling
humanity drawing humanity towards a bad
end i think another example would be um
like racism um you know kind of in the
united states our whole
history
of um
i mean it's there's always been this
kind of
uh looming threat of like a kind of a
a genocidal kind of insanity just sort
of looming in the background you know
just and it comes out and it manifests
and it kind of goes back and it's just
like it's sort of like the shadow side
you know of if people have a shadow side
it's almost like cultures and whole
communities can have a shadow side and
that's sort of
always been there
and we could say you know like well
that's just that's just human psychology
just human psychology like you know we
fear we just we're afraid of that which
is different we fear that which is
different and we try to like control it
or or um reject it or exploit
people you know and so this is just
human psychology this is just what we do
you know um
and i would say
maybe maybe
perhaps
but perhaps not perhaps those ancient
christians were
kind of onto something perhaps peter was
onto something that that there are evil
forces playing on that psychology
manipulating it trying to call us
towards not the good the beautiful the
true but evil
um insanity lies
and um
i think you know
this can be somewhat a cause for despair
you know i mean like oh gosh i don't
think humanity like we don't need help
being bad you know um and so this you
know this idea of evil forces like this
could be um quite depressing i came
across a quote this is from daniel
schmoktenberger
it's quite a last name huh
schmuckton very strong i guess german
background i don't know um
but he he said this he said we now he's
talking about humanity we now have the
power of gods but we lack the wisdom and
love of gods
um he by the way he's not a christian or
anything he's just a
kind of a secular thinker
he's very much concerned for humanity um
now what does he mean you know we now
have the power the power of gods
um i think i used this quote maybe a
year ago so some of you might be
familiar um but basically he's talking
about like well for example like nuclear
weapons
that'd be a good example you know you
think of like the quote-unquote gods of
old you know zeus with the light oh the
power of a lightning bolt whoa
the power of gods you know like well
what's a nuke
my goodness we now have the power of
gods
you know i mean you think of like uh
maybe the gods could have spoken with a
loud voice
and thousands of people could have heard
them at once
you know
i mean you think of like
technology how it amplifies a voice
whoosh
i mean like people someone famous or
powerful can speak a word and whoosh
it's all over the world
it's like the power of a god
but what do we lack that's where i think
that quote is so insightful
we lack the wisdom and love of i
wouldn't go plural i'm a christian
but we lack the wisdom and love of god
we have all this tech i mean this is um
this is where i think kind of technology
sort of promises us you know salvation
we're going to shape the world for good
you know
and it's like
at best a very mixed bag you know i mean
like on the one hand it's like things
can get better
and it's like we make them tear like so
much worse at the same time does that
make sense like you know bio weapons is
a good example like we have this
technology and like on the one hand we
can create you know technology to help
feed the world you know
and then we use similar technology and
we create biological weapons that could
like wipe out the planet ten times over
you know it's like oh we have the power
of gods now but we lack the wisdom and
love of god another example i'm old
enough to remember the uh kind of
utopian days of the internet
anyone old enough to remember when it
was like
the information age
is upon us
like the little sound as you're logging
on you know it's like oh my gosh email
everyone watch the movie you've got mail
you know it's like wow the internet we
can come it's like so cheap too it's
free i can communicate with anyone and
send it for free you know and all the
the kind of uh
technologists were like oh it's amazing
like it's gonna be just free information
to the to the world to everyone and this
is gonna like unleash creative power and
potential for all humanity and and some
of that's true right like it has sort of
unleashed all sorts of things and like
and so like on the one hand like yeah
kind of but then at the same time what
you played out for like 20 25 30 years
whatever it's been now and what happens
we've created a misinformation
hellscape
i mean am i exaggerating like if people
go online
no one can agree it's like i don't trust
no you're wrong
no that's not true actually no no you're
misinformed you're missing no no no
right everyone like the the i've heard
some people call it like
schmachtenberger god i like that last
name uh he calls it like the the
information ecology if you think of like
nature and you know ecology he's like
our information our ecology it's like
it's polluted it's a
mess
in what was going to be the information
age will lead us to
the promised land you know has turned
into oh a mess a mess you can see here
um
we're very much kind of knocking on the
door the message last week with the
theologian fleming rutledge when she
said something is wrong and must be put
right
when we feel that in our bones
then god is at work bringing us closer
to the cross
of
christ
um
because you see honestly like whether
you i don't know i don't know how all
that the demon talk struck you you know
evil forces malevolent powers the
principalities and powers operating
behind the scenes of history i don't
know how that connected or didn't with
you but honestly um
for the purposes of this message and i
think what this text really means for us
i
your own thoughts and opinions on that
on that are like hey that's that's cool
i'd be super open to dialogue you know
um i think it's really honestly neither
here nor there
um here's what i think we we could agree
on there are technological institutional
and ideological forces much bigger than
me
at work in the world
and they are dragging humanity towards a
bad end we have the inmates have escaped
the asylum
so cute
don't worry that wasn't one of my most
important lines it's fine
no i love it honestly let's let's um
remember children they're always a
blessing i know a lot of churches i'm
being completely serious like churches
that would
long for that problem right there
you know i mean like to see the next
generation to have them in the space and
the energy and the love and it's
beautiful
it's a good thing that's a good thank
you thank you thank you carter
um
all right
let me back up honestly it's neither
here nor there your thoughts
i'm like a robot that just goes back to
script it isn't either here or not there
what you think about it
um
let me say it again there are
technological
um institutional and ideological forces
much bigger than me much bigger than you
and i at work in the world and they're
dragging humanity towards a bad end the
way i kind of summed this up was um like
in the same way well we're like we're
five-year-olds playing with guns
you know as humanity we are like you
don't give a five-year-old guns and you
don't give human beings nuclear weapons
you know you just
you don't
do it
um
now
you say oh my gosh what a mother's day
message this has been say what where is
the hope
where is the hope so depressing um
well honestly i mean
this is this is why i'm a christian
this is why it's like there's the the
old saying like you can't go to heaven
until you go to hell you know like a
like a movie that just kind of jumps you
to heaven it sort of feels cheap and
dumb and like you know it's not you got
to go to hell before you go to heaven
like and i think in a similar way you
don't really understand the gospel it
was flaming religious quote right you
don't get it you don't get it until
something within you is like oh my gosh
we are done for
we are done like if you think like no i
think human means we can really turn
this around we're just like a few tweaks
away and it's like
i disagree i mean i think things get a
little better but also like a lot worse
you know it's like oh
and it's in that moment
like i mean
this is why i'm a christian heck this is
why we planted a church
you know is like
um
i think let me let me kind of come back
the hope is the gospel
and yes there are technological
institutional and ideological forces at
work in the world that are trying to
drag humanity towards a very bad end
that's true
but
but there is also the god we have come
to know
in jesus christ
and the powers
those principalities powers those forces
of evil
put him to death on a cross
but
god has raised his servant and son jesus
from
the dead and he has promised that what
god has done for jesus
he will one day do
for all creation including you and i
and that is
our hope
that that god is god
that jesus is
lord
like that's good news and so here would
be this would be like if i had to give
you like the heart of first period 3
18-22 not a translation of it um
with
not that but like if i could just give
you the kind of the modern take of like
uh the heartbeat of it i would sum it up
like this thanks be to god
governments institutions ideologies
principalities and demonic powers are
not lord facebook and ford motor company
are not lord humanism and racism and
every form of ideology are not lord
capitalism and communism and commanders
in chief are not lord jesus christ is
lord and he gets the last word
he gets the last word and
and so so this is what it means to be
christian
is not to see all of the crap in the
world and there's plenty
and despair
you know
it's it's to see it all
with clear eyes
to see it all name it all
and at the same time to be people of
great hope
to say god you can
you you are up to something in the world
and i would like to be part of it
part of the healing i think this is why
peter um
where he goes is he starts talking about
baptism i think that's the invitation
for us verse 21 this water symbolizes
baptism that now saves you also what is
baptism in our tradition we aren't
really the sprinkling types though
that's fine i don't think god's like oh
no that's not real baptism you know it's
like what else but i think i do love the
symbolism of going under the waters
right because it's uh it's a picture of
death
and what
resurrection
and um we talked last week about sin and
like personal sin and such and so it is
a death to that right our own addictions
and craziness and all the you know all
the stuff that messes up our lives it is
a death to that
but what is it also it's the stuff we've
been talking about tonight it's a death
to all those old those institutions
ideologies
powers the things that we just feel like
i'm out of control i'm just i have to i
have to be committed to those things i
don't know what else to do and it's a
it's a dying to all that
and then we are we are raised to new new
life in jesus christ
and um in fact there's a beautiful
um little tradition i'll close of this
in the the
very very early church
um where when they were just before they
were baptized like literally moments
um they had this um saying
that it was like you had to do it um
right before you're baptized this is i
want to get the quote right they would
yell out
i renounce satan in all his works and
ways
and they would literally
face like the north the south the east
the west and like yell that out i
renounced satan in all his works and
ways they would do it like four times
very dramatic and again
i get people like i don't know about
satan as an actual being
like okay whatevs can you see the
in light of everything we've been
talking about
like
facebook and ford motor company and all
the
powers and institutions and ideologies
and politicians and all the ways of the
world right and that's what they're
naming is like i'm done with
that
i'm leaving that behind and and what am
i doing i'm following jesus
the crucified one
the resurrected one
um because if you think of what is
crucifixion it's it's a it's a picture
of suffering love
and that's really what we're committing
to as christians
is the cruciform way the way the way of
the cross
the way of the cross and
it's not the wisdom of this world
because the ways of the world all those
institutions and ideologies and powers
and they're they have no interest in the
way of the cross you know like
um
but but to be christian is to say but
that's it's the wisdom of god
it's the wisdom of god
to love your enemy
to pray for those who persecute you
to be the servant of all
to seek to be not not the first
but the last
to lay down your life
why in order to find it in the end
so that's our call
that's our call as christians
so as we um
as we come to the table of the lord
jesus today i i want us to
um
well may it be maybe a weighty thing
you know and not just like cutesy
christian ritual you know like oh it's
nice sky god you know my weekly check-in
you know maybe maybe something deeper
than that may it be
iron out satan all his works and ways
you know for in whatever level that
means for you
you know like may it be i'm leaving that
behind
i'm leaving those things behind i want
to follow you christ i want to love you
i want
i want to
i want to be part of the solution in
this world
right and that's that's really what
we're doing as we take in the bread it's
a symbol of his broken body as we take
in the wine it's a symbol of his blood
shed for us it's it's a picture of great
love and it's an identification
with that
it's saying yes i i want to take that
into me and then god would you transform
me in the process
so we practice at the table what's
called an open table
meaning if you're here tonight and you
would like to participate
then you're free to do that there's no
like doctrinal police we're not like oh
sorry you're not a member here you know
like you don't do that um just if you
would like to participate um then you're
you're free to do that
so let me uh invite you to the table
with this celtic christian invitation
this is the table
not of the church
but of the lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more
so come
you who have much faith
in you who have little
you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow in you who
have failed
come
come because it's the lord jesus himself
who invites you and it's his will that
those who want to meet him should meet
him here
come to the table
[Music]
so
um
before before we interact with god and
expect something you know
from him there's kind of that moment in
my heart where i'm holding the bread in
the cup and i'm reflecting on
what i've been like the last
week or two you know and there's that
moment of kind of like truth
at least that's what i feel often times
like here's this god that loves me so
much
and sometimes i'm not a great reflection
of someone who is loved
um and it reminded me of this moment
last night all of our kids were around
the pool playing together and there
weren't really any adults close by and
so they got in their own
game
where they weren't really worried about
who was listening or who was watching so
they played a game called confessions
that they created on the spot and every
time someone would get up on the big
rock ready to jump in they would have to
confess something and then jump into the
water so it became very entertaining
from a distance we were listening
and i heard my nephew get up on the
rocks a lot of people were just like i
did this thing one time i did that thing
my nephew gets up on the rock and he
says my favorite part about christmas is
the presents and then he jumps in the
water
and it just
the honesty
was so refreshing you know
i just loved it and
it's like i need more moments like that
with god
with the people in my life you know
where
you're
you're not afraid of putting up your
front you know
and you just are saying the thing that
we really need to say which is
oh man i'm so messed up sometimes
i don't have it together i am falling
short
i am in need and why is that so hard
sometimes just to share that honesty you
know
to speak that truth because
that's what i feel when i come to the
table is like oh man i need
i need jesus you know i need to live
like i'm loved
i need to remember that
i need to
experience him in a new way that
revitalizes all these dead parts that
i'm constantly trying to hide and
you know cope with
i just need him you know and that's what
this song is it's a confession
so if you guys want to stand during this
last one with us and let's just if you
feel open to it no pressure but if you
would like to just hold your hands out
just like you did when you received that
cup and that bread
and let this be our truth
god
we don't have it together
[Music]
our world is a muck
and we are a muck inside of it
and we need you
[Music]
how can
i respond
to the love that you have levish time
me
how can i respond
[Music]
i don't have much
i don't have
much
but i have a heart that beats for you
i have a heart
[Music]
every part
every part of me
[Music]
wants to love you like you loved
me lord
every part of me
wants to love you like you loved
[Music]
heart that beats for you i have a heart
that beats for you
i don't have much
but i have a heart that beats for you
i have a heart that beats for you i have
a heart that feeds for you
i have a heart that beats
[Music]
i'll give to you
i have a life i'll give to you
i have a heart that beats for you
i have a heart that beats for you i have
a heart that feeds for you i have a
heart that speaks for you
[Music]
oh
i don't have
much
i don't have much
but i have a heart that beats for you
i have a heart that beats for you
[Music]
feel
well i feel fancy now
um
family that was
that was beautiful thank y'all thank you
and to um
do a little piggyback ride on what mindy
said who did a piggyback ride on what
brett said we did a piggyback ride on
what peter said
um
i just want to say this community
that you have found yourself in tonight
whether it's online or you're listening
in the future
it truly is a place that
you can be vulnerable and you can be
yourself and you are wanted here in
whatever season or stage or beauty or
ugliness that is
the the table the heartbeat of the table
the pillars that were built on is
thoughtfulness
eclectic
vulnerability
communal
[Music]
inclusive hot dogget
inclusivity
and those aren't just words that are
fun
or hard to remember
but they are very intentional words that
that is what we are here for and if you
are needing to plug in if you're needing
community keep showing up and hop online
and join a meetup group we have several
of them that meet in all different
capacities
and it really is a place where you can
say this is where i'm in despair this is
where i'm sinking please throw me a
lifeline and you will find that
um
[Music]
and yeah i just thank y'all thank y'all
for that because it is the truth and it
truly is the heartbeat of this church
and of this family and you are wanted
here
um
i'm so glad you're here
at the back uh when you're leaving if
you're a visitor and you would like to
plug in more you can fill out a visitor
card and let us know that you were here
and if you're interested in the table
class next weekend right after the
service it'll be about an hour long
please put that on the back of the card
if you have questions or you just want
to
find out more we'd love to have you
there
and um
that yeah oh
if you call the table your church home
i
encourage you to
give whether it's through prayer or in a
monetary way it helps
put the fuel in all of our gas tanks
right
and the gas tank of the table so
you can do that online
and that is such a blessing and a gift
to us
um to you i mean we're to all of us
right we're we're all in it together um
i have a benediction which is just a
prayer a blessing for the road if you
would like to
close your eyes
and open take a posture of just
receiving this
prayer with me
lord god we rejoice in your greatness
and power your gentleness and love your
mercy and justice
equip us by your spirit to honor you in
our thoughts and words and actions
and to serve you in every aspect of our
lives give us the strength and wisdom to
renounce satan in all his works and ways
enable us to know deep in our bones the
truth
that we are known
we are wanted
we are needed
we are loved through jesus jesus christ
our lord
amen
go now in the name of the father the son
and the holy spirit if you need prayer i
will be standing at the back and i would
love to pray with you for you so i'll be
back there and i won't be so long-winded
[Music]
i don't have much
i a heart that needs for you
[Music]
beautiful